what were you frustrated about at the
end of the uh second quarter when you
got that
tactical uh I know I saw you when you
said about the fan you know that was not
a true all that was not the only thing
he said um but I knew you would be the
first one to to point out something like
that I'm not going to say what he said
but I knew you were going to be the
first one to put out something like that
so I just saw it man it's just funny you
always seem to be the first one to put
some bad stuff about me first of all 99%
of the stuff I've written about you has
been good I I don't know I was sitting
two rows behind
us all right so it was the only thing he
was that time he said something the only
thing that was what you reacted to yeah
I was hearing the whole first half right
or you didn't hear anything he was
definitely hollering okay there we go
well you put out something that was just
the only thing but was the final STW was
the final what was the thing that it's
not the issue I'm just seeing you seems
to be the first one to always put
something bad about me